il ya des mesures qui s'applique
aujourd'hui encore dans notre pays elles
sont levé progressivement partie des
mesures a été levé 2 février notre série
de mesures le 16 février j'ai toujours
dit s'agissant du pass vaccinale que
nous le lèveront dès lors qu'il y aura
une normalisation de la situation à
l'hôpital c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura
plus un hôpital sous très forte tension
du fait du covin on constate qu'il ya un
début d'amélioration à l'hôpital et il y
a le professeur fisher à l'adie des
projections des modélisations qui
peuvent nous laisser espérer
effectivement qu'à cet horizon de fin
mars début avril la situation se soit
suffisamment détendu à l'hôpital pour
que nous puissions levé le pass
vaccinale peut être aussi avancer sur la
question du port du masque évidemment
que nous le souhaitons tous et nous
l'espérons on a toujours dit que ces
mesures seraient levés dès lors que la
situation sanitaire le permettraient